[Musique]
gardez ça c'est la première partie de la
caméra cachée avec isabelle morini-bosc
serait la deuxième partie demain c'est
parti greg guillotin piège isabelle ça
lui sait gré guillotin nous avons décidé
de figer une partie des chroniqueurs ne
touche pas à mon poste pour ça nous
avons fait appel à la complicité de
cyril hanouna il a ainsi dit aux
chroniqueurs qu'il fallait qu'ils
rencontrent youtuber talentueux sur
quitté pmp a décidé de s'appuyer la
saison prochaine pour être davantage
présents sur le web sur youtube heures
c'est moi et je vais camper un mec
insupportable aux foulards énorme et je
vais piger les chroniqueurs avec la
complicité de delphine une
collaboratrice de cyril et de david mon
associé aujourd'hui isabelle morini-bosc
première partie à la base je me joins
cartonne sur le web
donc c'est pour ça que cyril qui a eu un
coup de coeur pour mes vidéos m'a dit
nous on est dans une volonté de chez
qu'ils aient un peu l'émission et suis
un peu toutes les casseroles que vous
travaillez au cul certains qui sont plus
concernés que d'autres je dois avoir
courbé après je dois voir questa je
m'expliquerai avec eux mais en gros toi
tu va me faciliter un peu la tâche
ciré lui qui a ses fans de moi a
considéré que j'ai incarné l'élégance et
le charme qui manquait à cette émission
s'agit bien boutabout ses skis et c'est
ce qui est vrai alors c'est vraiment ça
toi tu vas sûrement pas en colère
milwaukee mais j'invite tout simplement
parce que j'ai pas le temps de douter
des petits enfants qui me connaissent je
remercie non j'ai un fils pour l'instant
ça ne s'écrit pas d'accord ok j'ai mon
caractère pour palm pixi tout sinon ses
pingouins avec moi je suis un sillon sur
internet on va dire qu'à chaque vidéo
que je sors je me régale la toile
concernant mon travail ici moi je suis
censé vous aider tous davantage avec moi
c'est qu'on part d'une page vers ta
carrière elle a débuté assez récemment
je pense que tu étais dans les licences
et les gens de ma génération qui me
connaissent le concernant c'est comment
tu t'es retrouvé là est-ce que c'est
franck kita introduite auprès d'eux
de serre et les 30 big series et cyril
duc c'est lui et peu importe
37 ont cessé ce assez pour franck habito
je parle à non moi je parlais de jim de
duboscq a annoncé pascal aucun rapport
moi je m'appelle basse c'est aussi parce
que pour moi c'était la mère de son du
boss en fait non mais ce temps là si on
doit avoir 10 ans j'étais persuadé
qu'ils étaient simplement d'un an je te
remercie m ok ok je continue à radio
aujourd'hui oui ok parce que pour moi en
fait la radio vont nous est pas rémunéré
pour ça en fait c'est servir la nation
arabe et je suis en cdi j'ai un vrai
salaire chaque mois donc moi ça m'ennuie
un petit peu parce que là on va mélanger
un peu les échos ce thème je te faire
sortir d'artane gentil ni tête et sortir
bien pressée qui l'image dans c'est à
dire que je t'ai devoir pour que votre
phase arrêtée la rade jeunes car l'un
d'eux en ces lignes
oui mais même si tu as quelques piges en
radio je veux dire c'est pas une
présence quotidienne de deux chroniques
quotidiennes l'avantagé que tu vas te
reposer le coup tu seras plus ensemble
pour faire les projets que je vais te
proposer en fait
maury du monde aujourd'hui à l'antenne
on ne sait pas trop où on sait qu'elle
est la mauricie wouri du losc le dis
tout de suite un an ça me suffira pas
pour te développer je vais pouvoir faire
quelque chose de toi en 2-3 pas si bien
ça va mais c'est ça c'est au moins tu
peux tenir le soldat on est bon quoi
même cas pas avant entre les bras c'est
tout simplement
est-ce que je peux conseiller non il n'y
a pas de moteur on n'est pas là pour ce
maladroit dire autant des raisons de sa
ferme bien si non alors
vas-y donc aujourd'hui là on va rentrer
dans le vif du sujet ça va être ma
proposition
moi ce que je veux c'est que la marque
maury du boss tu vois un moment donné
est réel jézabel d'isabey la radio déjà
on va se faire stopper mais ce qui va
rester le coeur névralgique de ta
carrière pour moi ça va être la chaîne
youtube maury du bastion morini-bosc il
parle ok je vais corriger tout de suite
concrète à chelles ce que j'imaginais un
jeu c'est qu'alain et toi vous mettez
face caméra et tu télécharges temps réel
des bruits de pets et il doit retrouver
le quelle sorte de tfs un agent c'est un
peu même les vieux ont beaucoup de
chance
ce que je veux dire c'est que ça colle
là c'est très sérieux
tu vois en jouant bien faut que tu
fasses des truc de vieux 00h30 jeunes
sahraouis en fait je comprends maurice
que tu veux dire mais juste
l'idée c'est plus le thème que tu vas
faire maintenant tu vas me dire la
question c'est comment on amène les gens
sur la chaîne youtube et de me retrouver
la suite de l'épisode avec l'idée
géniale que j'ai proposé à isabelle pour
lancer sa carrière
mais j'étais sûr que la plus connue en
france est nulle
[Applaudissements]
l'otan est exceptionnel ah ouais